-Welcome, everybody!
Please.
-Happy --
-Love you, Jimmy!
-I love you.
Happy Thri-day!
-Thri-day, I love it.
-Yeah.
-[ As Rebecca Black ]
♪ Thri-day ♪
-I didn't make that up, right?
Is that a thing?
-It is now.
-Happy Thri-day?
-It's Thursday.
-Yeah, but I'm -- Thri-day.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause the energy --
I'm already
in the weekend already.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, guys,
this Sunday is Father's Day.
That's right. So --
[ Cheers and applause ]
So make sure you call your dad,
even though
you'd both prefer a text.
[ Laughter ]
But talking with Dad
on Father's Day is fun.
It's a great way to catch up
on which neighbors
are annoying him
for which reasons.
[ Laughter ]
"This guy parks his car in front
of his house all the time.
[ Laughter ]
This guy, he plays his music --"
"Okay, good, Dad."
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
Father's Day is this Sunday,
and Americans are expected
to spend over $20 billion.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
That story, again --
on Sunday, over 20 billion
scratch-off tickets
will be sold.
[ Laughter ]
"Good luck, Dad."
Let's get to some news.
After his week-long trip
to Europe, President Biden
is finally back
in Washington, D.C.
When he saw his schedule filled
with meetings on infrastructure,
immigration, and inflation,
his first thought was,
"I already miss Putin."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, returning home
was pretty emotional for Biden,
mostly 'cause
on the flight there,
he realized that he
"Home Aloned" Pete Buttigieg.
[ Laughter ]
"Pete!"
"Keep the change,
you filthy animal!"
[ Laughter ]
But this is big.
Today, Biden signed
the Juneteenth National
Independence Day Act...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...making Juneteenth
a federal holiday!
[ Applause ]
The bill hit Biden's desk after
it was passed in Congress,
but 14 members of the House
voted against it.
[ Audience booing ]
Can we --
Can we see who they were?
Yeah.
-Oh.
-That's -- That's about right.
That's about right.
[ Laughter ]
That looks like the white-paint
sample section at Home Depot.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"What do you think, honey?
Should we paint the bathroom
Mike Rogers or Thomas Massie?"
[ Laughter ]
And I saw this -- Jared Kushner
just signed a book deal.
Yep, his book will come out
next year.
But he already
has a few titles in mind.
Check these out.
First --
-Ah, here we go.
-What's up, dude?
-Let me guess.
Well, you're gonna make fun
of Jared Kushner, right?
By saying a bunch
of fake book titles.
-I mean...yeah,
that was the plan.
-And, of course, each title
will pop up as a graphic,
so everyone can see it
and "laugh" about it.
[ Laughter ]
-Right.
That's kind of what I do.
It's the whole first
10 minutes of the show.
-I -- I know exactly
how this will go down.
Okay, the top of the screen
will have, like, a weird picture
of Kushner, and it'll say,
"Kushner's Book Titles."
And then, under that,
you'll list fake titles, like,
"50 Shades of White."
[ Laughter ]
Or -- Or
"Diary of a Wimpy Adult."
[ Laughter ]
Or "Are You There, Don?
It's Me, Your Creepy
Son-in-Law."
[ Laughter ]
And then you'll do,
"Eat, Pray, Ask Daddy
for a Million Dollars."
[ Laughter ]
Oh, or -- or "Gone With the
Slightest Gust of Wind."
[ Laughter ]
And then you'll finish it off
with something like,
"The Sun Also Rises (While I
Sleep Standing Up in a Coffin)."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
I'm guessing
that's how this is gonna go.
-Yeah.
You nailed it.
-Well, that's a fun bit.
You should do it.
[ Laughter ]
-All right.
We'll do it tomorrow.
Perfect.
[ Laughter ]
Well, guys, get this.
I read that for next year's
Super Bowl, a 30-second ad spot
will cost a record $6 million.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
And apparently, some companies
are already testing out
shorter ads to avoid high costs.
I mean, just --
just check this out,
this new ad I saw from Old Navy.
Look at this.
-As you know, we here
at Old Navy sell clothes.
[ Laughter ]
-I just --
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Check out this ad
I saw from Home Depot.
-Plywood, lamps, shovels,
things of that nature.
[ Laughter ]
-"Things of that nature"?
-Wow!
-These are rough.
Here's the last one here,
from Olive Garden.
-Breadsticks.
When you're here --
[ Laughter ]
-"Breadsticks when you're here."
-Gets to the point.
-Breadsticks when you're here.
-Yeah.
Some business news.
I heard that rental-car prices
are at a record high
and could even double by August.
-Ooh.
-Yeah.
For car renters on a "Budget"
hoping to save a "Dollar"
to see the "Alamo,"
this news is --
this news really "Hertz."
[ Laughter ]
Goodbye, everyone,
and see you all at the Emmys.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Wow!
Wow!
-Well, guys, with COVID
restrictions lifting
all over the world,
a lot of countries
are opening back up
to tourists this summer.
In fact, many of them have
released updated travel posters
to help entice visitors.
Take a look at these.
This first one is for France.
It says, "We're still gonna
stand 6 feet away,
but it's just because
we don't like you."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Wow!
-Again --
This next one's
for the United Kingdom.
It says, "The pubs are open,
and the sun is shining.
Okay, the second one's a lie."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Here's one for Fiji.
It says, "Not just a Zoom
background anymore."
[ Laughter ]
-Oh.
-This next one is for Estonia.
It says, "Come figure out
whatever our deal is."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Finally, this last poster's
for Spain.
It says,
"The sooner you come back,
the sooner you can brag
to your friends
that you went to 'Bar-thelona.'"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, I went to Bar--
Oh, we had so much fun.
-Where'd you go?
-What's that?
-Oh, we just went to --
We just went to Bar-thelona.
-Oh, really?
-It was just so --
It was so fun.
-How long were you there?
-We -- We were there two days.
In Bar-thelona?
-Yeah.
-We were -- Well, one day.
It was a layover.
-Not a week?
-It was a couple hours.
-Yeah.
-But, yeah.
I had so much fun.
I felt like --
I'm just, like, some part of me
was from Bar-thelona.
-Really?
[ Laughter ]
-Guys, listen to this.
A computer programmer
in the Philippines
gave his newborn son
the name
Hypertext Mark-up Language.
Or HTML, yeah.
[ Audience groans ]
Yeah, I'm pretty sure the baby's
first word will be, "Why?"
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a new study out
of the U.K. found that
the aging process
is unstoppable.
[ Laughter ]
When they heard that,
a bunch of people in L.A. said,
"We beg to differ."
We have a great show.
Give it up for The Roots!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Let's have it, Mr. Onassis ♪
♪ Drop top rips ♪
♪ My dreads could go hatless ♪
♪ My, that boy's spits and riffs
are so savage ♪
♪ Making C seem
so below-average ♪
♪ Everyone in the cave
but go back in ♪
♪ Everybody know that, though,
Bo Jackson ♪
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Imitating guitar strumming ]
-Do you always know --
Do you always know what jam
I'm gonna like?
-Yeah, of course.
-You do. So you knew that I was
gonna like that one?
-Yeah, yeah.
-[ Imitating guitar strumming ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Imitating crashing noises,
screeches ]
-What a show we have
for you tonight.
She stars
in the new movie, "F9."
Helen Mirren is here!
-Oh, come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-God, I love Helen Mirren.
-Plus, joining us in studio --
I love this guy.
He's -- He's brilliant.
He's a genius.
His brain's always moving, man.
I love this guy.
He produced the upcoming Netflix
series, "We The People."
Kenya Barris is here!
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And we got great music
from Noel Gallagher's
High Flying Birds!
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Then, of course,
an all-new "Thank You Notes"
later in the show.
Well, as I mentioned, everyone,
Father's Day is this Sunday.
A lot of people are shopping
for that perfect card.
And while there are a lot
of good choices,
there are also some very
unpopular cards out there.
I'll show you what I mean.
-Really?
-What?
-There's unpopular cards?
-There are -- There are some
unpopular cards.
-Well, I'd love to see them.
[ Laughter ]
-Would you like me to show you
with some examples?
-Could you, please?
Do you have time?
I don't want to get in your way,
if you have time.
-No. No problem.
-If you don't have time,
I'll, you know --
-No. I -- I never said
I didn't have time.
-Oh, okay.
Well, I don't want
to stop the show, but...
-No, you -- pssh!
Too late now, you know?
[ Laughter ]
But I'll give you some examples.
-Please.
I'd love to see them,
'cause I don't know
what you're talking about.
I'd like to see
-Well, hey, this one's for you.
-Thanks, man.
Happy Father's Day.
-This is an example
of some unpopular cards
on Father's Day.
-Okay.
-For instance, this card says,
"I can't begin to describe how
much I love and admire you."
-Aww.
-Open it up, it says,
"So I'm hoping
this sleeve of golf balls
does the talking for me."
-Oh.
[ Applause ]
Unpopular.
-These are unpopular cards.
This next card says,
"You've taught me so much,
like how to make one simple
errand take all day."
-Oh.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Kind of a slam.
-These are un --
-These are unpopular.
-No, these are -- exactly right.
-They're more of dis
towards the father figure.
-Well, no, I'm just saying,
these are --
-Not the popular card.
If you're going to
the card section,
that'd be the one --
there'd probably be a lot
of these left over,
'cause they are not popular.
-Correct.
[ Laughter ]
This card says, "Thank you for
FaceTiming me through COVID.
The inside of your nose
never looked better."
-Oh.
That's rude.
[ Applause ]
Rude.
-That's nice.
-No.
-Here's another one that says,
"I'd do anything for you, Dad."
-Aww.
-"Except try to explain the
Marvel Cinematic Universe."
[ Laughter ]
It's too complicated.
[ Applause ]
Next card says,
"Thanks for doing so much work
around the house...
before we eventually
call a handyman
to fix everything you did."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Caulk, caulk.
-Caulk gun.
Caulk.
-My dad, that was his solution.
-He would caulk everything.
-He caulked everything.
Every -- the whole house was
made out of caulk at one point.
-Really? He made like a caulk
igloo, and stuff like that?
-Yeah, it was like -- yeah.
It was like --
Yeah, it looked like a --
Yeah, of caulk.
[ Laughter ]
It looked like a --
like a gingerbread house.
-Oh, wow.
-Like icing.
-Yeah, icing everywhere.
-Dripping down, yeah.
Except it was all caulk, yeah.
This next card says,
"I'm your son."
Inside it says,
"No matter how many DNA tests
you've made me take
to prove otherwise."
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's harsh.
That's a little rude.
-That's rude. That's mean.
-Then, finally, this card says,
"Dad, I can't wait."
Open it up, it says,
"To find this card in a box
in 30 years as proof
that you really did care."
[ Audience "Awws" ]
Those are some nice cards.
I love you, Dad!